whatever you can do is what you do it's
not about oh I have to be this guy I
have to be able to run 13 miles it's
like hey if it's a half a mile a mile
I'm doing it I'm feeling something I'm
going to go back I'm going to home I'm
going to rest I'm going to ice I'm going
to do whatever it takes to take care of
yourself I mean I'm I'm I'm guessing
that's what you do because you said
something with your size yeah no totally
yes yes I mean there's like you know
people talk about the Power of Now all
the time right I mean we've got the
ecares of the world um shouting from the
rooftops that we should focus on the now
right well what is the now it's meeting
ourselves where we are in that moment
and there we have to bring some
compassion for ourselves there's a lot
of love in being willing to meet
ourselves where we are and I you know
for for the longest time uh I would
punish myself with the kind of abuse um
like even in the gym where I go like if
I die on this treadmill I've won that
was my mental philosophy working out if
I die doing this workout I be I I beat
the game like I won and that's there's
no love in that there's no love in that
so so we've got to find the fine line
between pushing ourselves to be better
tomorrow than we are today but we can
get there by finding compassion for who
we are and meeting ourselves at our best
where we are right now you know so um
yeah that's important and and where I'm
at right now physically you know I'm I'm
wearing a lot of weight for the roll of
Reacher 240 wait 240 well 240 I mean I'm
probably actually you know I've been
working out pretty I'm probably 245 now
but um um a little heavier now but yeah
I'm I'm that's a lot of weight you know
so like for me to be running around the
hills um not
easy what what hurts what a what a big
guys uh you know you got a lot of these
guys like my my friend Dave Bautista and
you got Jason Mamoa and you got because
I really put you on that you're on that
tier to me you're like uh you're super
talented and your comedic timing is
amazing so I'm like you know I want to
get into that I want to get into to your
trajectory and all that but in terms of
like your size like is it really hard on
certain parts of your body to be that
big um I think it's hard on the heart
you know I mean um think about like so
there's a couple things that I start to
feel it's um the lung capacity feels
like I just can't keep up you know um
like if I I did Sprints this morning and
it's just amazing how quick I'm
like like really winded and it did
wasn't always like that but I'm trying
to get a lot of oxygen to a lot of
muscles but uh you know I weigh 240
pounds and I'm you know if I'm climbing
there's some hills out here where I am
where I'll I'll run these Hills if I'm
climbing up a hill it's a little bit
like doing lunges for 20 minutes
straight I mean throw for most people
throw 280 on your shoulders and do 20
minutes of lunges your muscles are going
to explode so I feel like when I'm
running I start to feel my muscles
aching just because it's like it's just
I'm pushing a lot of weight
one one one step at a time you know
without without breaking and you you
know you feel that so it's tough It's
you got to make adjustments when you're
you're wearing this kind of size and
some of the guys you mentioned like mimo
and all them you know um you know he's
got his out you know he's like a world
class rock climber you know so he's
there's some activities that he does
like insane like a a spider monkey um uh
you know but I don't think he's out
there
running you know so I've got to make
some you know we got to make adjustments
for that kind of thing do you think that
there's a time in your life where you'll
sort of I mean because to maintain that
and a lot of times you look at these
guys and they're if they ever stop
working out well they're probably gonna
be
fat yeah right so I had a have you ever
had a dexa scan uh no what is that do
you know what that do you have you aexa
scan is um a fancy new scan um a little
bit like it's kind of lik laying in an
MRI machine kind pruvo I did pruvo where
a body scan a body skin right and it'll
tell you your muscular composition your
body fat composition it tells you like
like you'll know all your sizes
measurements but you'll also get your
caloric uh your caloric values so you're
going to know exactly what you need to
maintain your size if you want to gain
weight how you know so for me I'm just
shy of 4,000 calories a day just to
maintain just to maintain so um so if I
if I stop working out for a little bit
and I'm still on that you know I've
trained my body to even 4,000 calories a
day it would take me about three weeks
to blow up you know um so it does take a
lot of consistency I work out five days
a week you know it's got to be a
lifestyle hey guys I'm doing another
live podcast downtown LA at the Regent
Theater and my special guest for January
24th is Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad
Jessica Jones this is going to be a
soldout event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited